years of the democratic and republican
nominees for president
coming up in about 25 minutes we'll talk
with jack buckley a former state
representative who worked for michael
dukakis
but first we'll air an interview with
william sloane coffin president of sane
freeze an anti-nuclear organization
mr coffin went to phillips andover
academy in massachusetts and was a
classmate of vice president bush
[Music]
[Music]
reverend william sloane coffin president
of the organization organization sane
freeze you are a classmate of george
bush's how did you first get to know him
well he was rather well known he was one
of these
lads who matured quickly
some people say because they have left
to mature with but he was very
well known
very popular he's a very nice guy
and i think he was vice president as i
remember of our class or the school
and he was a hot shot first baseman so i
knew him more generally than i did
personally though we were in a german
class as i remember together
what did you think of him in german
class
uh einstein once said imagination is
more important than knowledge i would
not say that applied to george bush he
did not have much imagination but he had
he was very conscientious he worked very
hard so generally you liked him oh yeah
yeah
we all did i imagine he
it is said most good men have to boast a
few enemies but i don't think at that
time
he uh had any i think he's just a
generally very well liked and deservedly
so these were the high school years at
phillips phillips academy and
massachusetts
tell me about that school what is it
like
school is intellectually one of the it
still is and certainly was then one of
the very top ones you know eastern
boarding school you have accident
andover hotchkiss choute
saint paul grant and all those schools
and
it was larger than most a little more
democratic
than most and that they had a lot of
scholarship money available
i don't know how many blocks there were
in those days there weren't money in any
of those schools
but
what i remember most about it was the
excellence of the teaching i really was
very grateful for everything i learned
there
would you say that it was a school for
the so-called privileged class yeah
yeah i think most of us there would
certainly be
call certainly privileged just to be
there but a lot of us were to the matter
born probably came from wealthy family
certainly that was the case in
bush certainly that was true in bush's
case
what was the atmosphere like school
morale things like that hi you know a
bunch of boys really working hard and
excellent athletics
um
i wanted to be a concert pianist so i
was practicing uh four hours a day
but there was a kind of school that
allowed me to do that and i spoke
excellent french so they forgave me the
french requirement and uh so it was good
in music and it was good in the arts
it was uh
it was and still is it's a terrific
school
academic pressure pretty tough yeah lots
of it
but uh
i wouldn't say that i don't remember it
as being wicked in any way you know i
mean we all wanted to go to college i
wanted to go to conservatory
but uh it was very good teaching i mean
i remember particularly uh
my american history teacher arthur
darling and i wish george bush would
remember arthur darling because arthur
darling had a shing to our embarrassment
the marine hymn from the halls of
montezuma to the shores of tripoli we
fight our country's battles and so forth
and any gentlemen there were no women
then gentlemen what the hell was the
united states doing there
in other words she was the first one to
really force me to ask the question
what right does the united states have
to decide who lives who dies and who
rules in small
other countries
other countries of the world
and that was the first time that was
that idea was firmly implanted in my
brain and i would have thought it would
be implanted in george bush's brain but
the way he talks about grenada he'd
never know that he had been taught if he
was by arthur darling
well i think it's fair to say that the
two of you ended up in on different
parts of the political spectrum anyway
did andover start to shape you
politically
i don't want to be self-serving but to
me it's almost a moral spectrum
see i don't feel
his concern
i don't feel his passion yeah i don't
feel i didn't then you know but then
one wouldn't expect it i mean he never
was known for a passion for the poor for
instance
he wasn't particularly political at that
point i remember his father you know was
a very liberal republican
senator from uh connecticut
so what was your question well did it
shape did did you start to think in
terms of
civic duty or public service i mean
after all you ended up in a type of
public service
were your political thoughts beginning
to be formed yeah very much in andover
particularly in the study of american
history
darling was the first one to really
make me understand what the united
states had done to the indians that our
country basically
is founded in the blood of 10 million
indians and develop the sweat of 40
million slaves i mean that's something
you have to take seriously when you're
an american now darling was the first
one to really push
me to really understand that push
everybody in the class so i i owe him a
lot that's when my
he made me think about a lot of things i
wouldn't normally think of
what other influences did andover have
on you
um
well again
it was mostly academic and intellectual
i had a very good english
history course i can tell you the entire
17th century english history i loved it
literature of course we had a wonderful
drunk
teaching us uh
literature he was we adored him he came
in with big dark glasses and hung over
but gee what a wonderful teacher you
know
those are the main recollections i have
and then of course some classmates who
were really quite super brilliant a guy
named link clark he's now a doctor
psychiatrist
and the fact that the school gave me the
chance to go ahead with my music which i
wanted very much and we sang in the
gleep club we had an orchestra i played
a beethoven concerto with the orchestra
that kind of thing you mentioned that
george bush was uh an athlete at andover
how important was sports to the the
school
how do you mean
why in all prep schools
you know being a
scholar and a gentleman and an athlete
that's the kind of
triumvirate they're trying to create and
so the trinity of qualities
discipline
yeah discipline wasn't uh
untoward i mean it was all useful
discipline it wasn't an aim in itself
but you had to be sober because
you had to study drunkenness was not
countenanced
you had to go to every class because
study is serious
that kind of thing in gary will's
article in time magazine of august 22nd
he notes that
during the end over years george bush
was dubbed best all-around fellow best
athlete most respected most popular
handsomest and most faculty drag
which he goes on to explain what that
actually means he says this last in
recognition of faculty popularity
because bush was so gladly submissive to
the ordeals of sarcasm that a student
with poor grades was expected to put up
with
my point there really is do those do
best all around fellow best athletes and
so forth did did they mean a lot
in
andover wow
i wouldn't say they meant more there
than they do in a high school senior's
book you know and there's they still
take votes who's the most popular you
know
all around suggests possibility of a
doughnut
that there wasn't a core of conviction
there you know
i never sensed george's passion
but he was a very nice guy
now there is an important difference
between a nice guy and a good man
a good man is somebody who has the
courage of his convictions a good man is
somebody who's willing to
uh look into the mirror that we'd all
rather veil
to change his mind and that sort of
thing
my chief recollection of george bush is
a very nice guy
and i would go further and say i think
today he is not campaigning according to
values that he holds dear i cannot
believe that george really believes
uh that this issue of the pledge of
allegiance to the flag is the real one i
think it's contemptible and i think if
he he was asked why you're doing it he
would not say because i believe it in
the bottom of my heart say because the
lore i stoop though i doubt if he'd say
this but the fact is the lower i stoop
the higher my popularity rises that's a
terrible reflection on the american
voter if true
well just so our viewers know what
you're all about tell us about the sane
freeze organization what is it well
shane free's the merger of the oldest
and the newest
peace and social justice organizations
they emerged a year ago we have about
180 000 members about 1400 chapters
throughout the country and basically
we're trying to wage peace on three
fronts one we believe that we've got to
reduce sharply
the number of nuclear and conventional
weapons in this world and we think the
soviets are ready and we should be
testing their sincerity a lot more than
we are and we should stop wars of
intervention whether in nicaragua or in
afghanistan again what right do we have
and darling first asked me this question
back in andover what right do we have
to decide who lives dies and rules in
small third world countries i don't see
we have any
uh that's why i think it's just
deplorable that he's back in the you
know the invasion of grenada even maggie
thatcher was against the grenadine
invasion 150 more countries voted
against it in the u.n as if it's our
patriotic duty to make our country a
moral pariah in the eyes of the nations
that's crazy
all right that's the second front no
wars of intervention and thirdly we're
hopeful that we can persuade our
government
to take the money shade through
disarmament and use it to help the
bottom 30 percent of the economic ladder
so based on what you know of george bush
back in those years you graduated when
42 40 1942. does it surprise you that he
is campaigning the way he is
well if truth be told
it was when he went out to texas that he
seemed to change then he became brown on
the bark and green on the leaf a real
chameleon you know and he began to hold
values quite different from those of his
father
and uh he would come on tough you know
every time he comes on tough i sort of
avert my gaze it's embarrassing that's
not the george bush i remember he wasn't
tough he was tough but he didn't have to
this false toughness you know
you're a woman you know uh the only the
truly strong can be tender
right okay
a little more tenderness than george
bush would be more typical of it yeah
it's just false macho stuff you know
well if you picked up the phone and
could get right through to george bush
and you had a couple of minutes to
advise him on what he should be doing
right now what would it be
well i would say george why don't you
campaign according to the values you
really hold
no this is
i understand you have to make certain
compromises to try to win
but uh there are limits beyond which
it's intolerable and to use uh the
pledge of allegiance to use the uh
prisoner thing you know and to talk
about defense without talking about what
threats
there are to our defense
is
there's no way to educate he's not
educating the american people
i'm i'm naive maybe but i'm sufficiently
idealistic to think that a campaign
ought to educate
and i think it's insulting to the
intelligence of americans
not to speak to their minds
and i would want him to address the
generous self which i still think is in
every american citizen and hasn't been
addressed for a long time mr reagan made
us comfortable in our prejudices
and i think bush is basically a very
decent guy but
that's why i say there's a difference
between nice guy and a good man
let's go back again for our last couple
of minutes and uh talk about yell you
both went to yale
and you both became
members i guess is the right word of uh
skull and bones right what is skull and
bones stone bones is one of years i've
forgotten how many there are 10 12
secret societies
which are made up of a small group of
seniors
and
let's say
they're somewhat elitist
we can certainly say that
and
but the climate of acceptance that's
created within the mix of a very warm
friendships and rakes through a lot of
candy
so the organization had an impact on
your life
not much in my life now
you have a uh
i guess a well-remembered or sort of a
renowned squash match that you played
with george bush what was that all about
well i think when he was a u.n
ambassador he came to yale for three
days as a so-called chub fellow
and i got a
mr chubb was the man who left the money
so people could important interesting
people could come for three days
and i got a call from somebody who said
uh the ambassador wants some exercise
would you be willing to play squash with
him he wants to play squash
so i said bring him on you know so we
went up the gym
and uh he doesn't play squash quite as
well as he plays baseball
and i was
not only a few years younger but quite a
few pounds
lighter so i just swept him in fine
shape but he wouldn't quit
i was really amazed i mean his tenacity
his competitiveness was really a little
almost alarming
and he wanted to continue so fine you
know i'm a little competitive myself you
know
and finally word spread through the gym
that the left wing was playing the right
wing on court too you know so we had
quite a crowd cheering us on and i
forgotten how many games and there was
some like nine we played before he
finally said okay enough he never won a
game i'm glad to say that was uh that
was my last uh
encounter with
george well what does that tell you
about the man
that he's very competitive
he wants to win
he's tenacious
uh
persistent all those things he certainly
wasn't a bad sport about it but he was
damned if he was going to lose if he
could possibly help it which he couldn't
all positive traits for the presidency
no
no no i wouldn't think so i mean a game
of the game come on
you know it's not that important and
there are always better players than you
are so you might as well recognize
i wouldn't make too big a deal out of it
are you following this race closely
yeah i'm disappointed in both of them i
think the caucus is being evasive and i
think bush has been contemptible
and i don't think the american public is
well served
i would hope that uh
we could really get the issues out there
they're very important
uh are we gonna work cooperatively with
other nations are we gonna take mr
gotobacho up on his office to reduce
conventional weapons in europe the 50
reduction the icbms the stopping of the
all testing by all nations for all time
nuclear tests these are very important
issues
and uh they're not being debated they're
not being discussed
and it's terrible that our great
democracy should be at its worst when we
celebrate that which makes us great our
elections and if we now slip under 50
percent of voters in the country both
candidates i think can be held somewhat
responsible for that
well thank you for your time reverend
coffin
i hope george has a happy retirement in
texas
thank you
[Music]
up next an interview with jack buckley
who was a state